well from onset Shenanigans to Onset
romances the Marvel Universe has given
us some serious relationship goals
I think Zendaya just showed up
yes my spider Lord
Tom Holland stopped to watch his lady
love Zendaya slay the red carpet for a
full 25 seconds before coming back to
our interview oh she's going in she's
going in she's going in she's gone
I think it's great to have that support
and that love around you the couple met
on the 2016 set of Spider-Man homecoming
and were rumored to be dating the
following year but it wasn't until 2021
when the duo was spotted kissing in his
car but we knew something was up when
Tom told us about borrowing Zendaya's
jacket I still have it I even saw her in
New York like two days ago she's like
can I have the jacket back I was like
yeah I don't I don't know where it is
I found you
he's really sexy when he's like been
fighting all day and he takes off his
mask and it's like
um he's steaming because it's so you
know he's so hot the steam Rises off of
his head she's like a really cool girl
really down to earth not to mention that
she's just a really incredibly sweet
pleasant woman you know what I mean
who's a joy to work with she's great Ben
Affleck and Jennifer Garner Fell in Love
on the set of Daredevil in 2003 when she
was still married to Scott Foley and he
was dating JLo I knew that I wanted to
do this movie because I wanted to work
with Ben the couple who first met while
shooting Pearl Harbor married in 2005. I
have to tell you and your wife you make
a handsome couple thank you so much I
know she definitely uh brings the
average up even though the two split in
2015 they still amicably co-parent their
three kids Violet Seraphina and Sam I'm
gonna do our best window try our best
but when it comes to being friendly exes
Emma Stone and Andrew Garfield have our
Spidey senses tingling she's just a son
and um but she's and she's got such
depth she can do anything
you know uh she's magic I don't know how
she does it
[Music]
real life couple after playing one in
The Amazing Spider-Man they dated for
four years before Calling it Quits but
these two are still tight we met uh the
screen test and uh
we we we just had a giggle we just we
just lost a lot and and kind of didn't
take it seriously and that was actually
the best the best way to do it he's just
he's just he's incredible
[Music]
foreign